Cowabunga dudes seems like a new teenage
mutant ninja turtles game is lurking in
the sewers just waiting to pop its head
out and grab a slice of pizza I'm Lucy
and welcome to this totally tubular
gamespot news update details of a new
TMNT game have leaked online via posting
on the Australian Classification Board
entry list to gain titled Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles mutants in Manhattan and
it's been developed by platinum games
and published by Activision the games
being rated M for mild impact themes
moderate impact violence and mild impact
language we've reached out to activation
comment and we'll report back as soon as
we hear anything now Platinum Games is
well known for its experience working on
several action games including the
critically acclaimed Bayonetta 2 as well
as metal gear rising revengeance Studios
currently developing the upcoming Star
Fox zero near automata and xbox one
exclusive scalebound the platinum are no
strangers to licensed games either
developing the legend of korra in 2014
and of course there must game was
transformers devastation another 80s
nostalgia hit published by none other
than Activision so what would you like
to see in a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
game could this be one of the big
reveals at this Thursday's game awards
let me know in the comments below i'm on
twitter at lucy James games and for all
the latest bodacious gaming news keeper
gamespot